hi my name is Emily Ekins and I'm the
director of polling at Reason Foundation
we recently conducted a poll a national
poll of Americans on both landlines and
cell phones we found that Obama
continues to lead Mitt Romney in our
poll 48 to forty three percent however
when you include undecided voters
Obama's lead increases substantially
from fifty two percent to forty five
percent unlike most polls we also asked
about libertarian presidential candidate
Gary Johnson Gary Johnson Garner's six
percent of the vote and when you include
him he actually takes votes away from
both President Obama and Mitt Romney
although the sluggish economic recovery
has dampened Americans confidence in the
economy they still are optimistic about
the American economic system and are
resistant to calls for redistribution 61
percent of americans believe that the
fact that some people in this country
are rich and others are poor is an
acceptable part of our economic system
and is not something the government
needs to fix one reason they may feel
this way is that fifty-nine percent of
americans think that individuals have an
equal opportunity to succeed in this
country although the pundants lament
congressional gridlock voters actually
may see this as a feature and not
necessarily a bug in fact forty-five
percent of voters would prefer Congress
passed fewer laws than they're doing now
only about a third said they wanted
Congress to pass more laws however there
is one law that voters overwhelmingly
would like to see Congress pass and that
is a lot of the Federal Reserve